[Music]
apologies to anyone um and
nope already it's bad
well that's part of it i guess so maybe
we should keep this now yeah this is
great so far we should keep it and just
make it like a really weird what
happened to them did he have a little
episode did he have a cerebral episode
well the truth is i i may have because
last night
uh when i was wrestling with my little
nephew i actually wasn't wrestling i was
rolling around on the floor and he was
my nephew's almost two and he was
pushing one of those little things he's
really into pushing things uh what do
they call it like a little um a little
pushy thing a little pushy thing yeah i
forgot the proper term you're right a
little pushy thing he was pushing
and i was pretending he was like hitting
me and i was rolling around and i rolled
into the wall and i hit
my head so hard that his mother my
sister-in-law and my mother both like
gasped they were like i was a little
scared because of how much it hurt and
how hard it was but um i saw my little
nephew's reaction and he got he kind of
seized up in fear so i pretended like i
was okay oh no that didn't i'm okay that
didn't hurt but um i don't know if
you've ever tried to do that while
dealing with like a pretty extraordinary
amount of pain
where you have to be like oh no no
everything's happened to me once too
when i was shooting the tv show ed i i
did a backflip and an improv and i
landed
square on my head
just to be funny i i have a story about
that oh you do yeah but let's get into
the show oh okay well uh yeah well i
want to hear your story after the uh
after the show on the show can we be on
the show okay good all right
if you if you stay tuned okay play your
cards right don't turn it off life could
be a dream life could be a dream
[Music]
you are currently listening to life is
short i'm your slightly woozy host
justin long
life could be a dream
[Music]
and with me as always is um
my brother who has his hands on his
waist waist waist
under your pants i'm wearing my viori
joggers oh and that sweatshirt's nice
what is that this is not an ad by the
way um it should be this is not from a
sponsor
nope it doesn't count my sweat don't you
like my sweatshirt it is unusually soft
and it's from theory wellness not a spot
not a sponsor and great parenting but
they gave it to me for free so i feel
like i need to acknowledge it's very
soft anyway um
so i'm feeling a little i'm feeling i'm
going to the doctor after that i can
tell you're feeling a little weird you
can huh
i i know that feeling of being
embarrassed yeah after getting hit
i don't know if i told you this story
but it's a short story i was in a
parking lot playing football with my
friends when i was in middle school and
i was running i know this for a pass as
fast as i could and i oh this is why
full sprint and i was looking back for
the ball to catch the ball and i caught
the ball
and mid stride i turned to go up field
up parking lot and i immediately
ran into a like a no parking sign or
uh some sort of sign and it
knocked me backwards and everyone
was like oh my god are you okay and
my
driving thought was this is embarrassing
yeah
it hurts yeah i'm sure it did hurt yeah
but i don't even remember the pain i
just remember the embarrassment of
people looking at me and being are you
okay and i was like yeah i'm totally
fine so i just like casually sauntered
to the bathroom and i remember looking
in the mirror and seeing like it was
like a looney tunes cartoon it was like
christmas pointing to his forehead a
little bummer it was like an egg it was
like a hard-boiled egg grew out of my
yeah that used to what happened to like
um
who would like the
who was the roosters i can't think uh
yeah um
it would be like
when they get hit with something a
little egg would appear uh the reason
we're talking about doctors and going to
having to do medical things is um
because sometimes and maybe it'll happen
to me today you have to give blood when
you go see the doctor and i was just
thinking i don't know my blood type off
hand i should know that i don't either
you don't bother to not know your blood
type that's something we should know uh
it could be oh
which is i think a rare one a negative
or it could be b positive
oh see what i did and i do see that's a
hell of a segue it leads me to believe
that you are fine yeah or maybe whatever
happened to my head has made me better
at segways but worse at other like motor
functions yeah that's funny um
we should write we should do our next
movie about that uh speaking of our
movie i want to thank everyone at the
sacred heart university community
theater we had an incredible screening
for it it was meant a lot to us um
because the movie theater that christian
and i grew up going to going into the
movies at so your segway's gone off the
rails i know it was it was going so well
well you derailed it i complimented it
yeah you're right i can't handle
compliments so be positive blood type
i got like emboldened to like do more
show stuff i'm like by the way a little
more housekeeping that we didn't have to
do but anyway thanks to yeah thank you
um but yeah be positive uh we're talking
about that sort of in a very roundabout
way because our guest today is on a show
a big show on cbs yep called be positive
uh her name is anna lee ashford
it's a cool name it is a cool name it's
emily ashford
it almost sounds made up it doesn't hurt
yeah it sounds like a victorian novel
yeah like intrigue and like i don't
think it is made up i think uh i mean
the first names made up obviously but i
think um like heathcliff wood annalee
it's very impressive yeah it's very
classical sounding and she's a very
impressive person she sure is so i feel
like her name fits her yeah very fun to
talk to i our family's gonna be uh
excited about this one because they're
big theater people we come from a big
theater family we sure do um and she is
a broadway star she's a huge broadway
star tony award-winning broadway anthony
and she gets to call it a tony because
she has one stupid stupid uh quite funny
kind of funny sorry i didn't mean to
[ __ ] on your joke yeah some people if
you like that joke write in and
tell us um but she was in you can't take
it with you which i saw her do she was
kinky boots i didn't see but um sylvia
yes
and so many great things
wicked um yeah i mean which everyone
knows um and now of course she's on the
show but she's also in another show
she's
safe to say she's blowing up she's blown
up literally
not literally figuratively um that'd be
a funny thing to misuse literally she's
literally blowing up i feel like i've
heard a version of that before i'm sure
we watched enough on the bachelorette
i've heard that um but she is they say
things like oh my god it literally made
me drop dead when i saw tony walk into
the rats i literally [ __ ] my pants so
it's an old david cross but um but she
was she's also in uh
american crime
what is it called oh boy oh i don't have
a doctor's appointment
it's got it's the impedance impeachment
american crime story
okay um but which i can't wait to see
and you've seen i'm a fan i'm into it
i'm hooked yeah it's so good it seems
very hookable oh so good you know who'd
be great to talk to is monica lewinsky
we should try to get her on the show
yeah but right now we have natalie
ashford and bill clinton
bill clinton
i'm sure he'd love to come on our show
he keeps asking yeah um we should get
them all on everyone involved in that
scandal so she is fantastic uh she plays
paula jones whom everyone remembers from
the 90s if you were of age during the
90s to remember that i do remember that
she uh opposite was iconic iconic at
this point paula jones friend of the
show a beanie felt steen's portrayal
that's right let's get into it yeah why
are we talking about it so much um let's
hear from the a wonderfully named
wonderful actress a wonderful person
anali ashford
life could be a dream sweetheart
this episode of life is short is brought
to you in part by audible gather the
family for story time magic with audible
listen to imaginative heartwarming and
festive stories original podcasts and
more brought to life by incredible
performers enjoy brand new audible
originals like the cinnamon bear
and exclusives like the christmas pig by
jk rowling fire up modern classics like
harry potter and the sorcerer's stone
and so many more all-time favorites
now's the time to listen together go to
audible.com slash listen together
that's audible.com
listen together listen now only from
audible
hello
[Music]
hi
hey hi
how are you where are you i'm in my
little podcast room
um room is kind it's like uh it's it's
like a large closet
in connecticut
oh great i'm in my weird dressing room
oh let's see yeah it looks
really good lighting really good
lighting oh you're on set you're you're
at oh you're at um wait don't tell me
radford
um close i'm at warner brothers same
same thing okay baby i'm down to cbs
show so it feels like the same thing are
you on the same lot as like
mom and
all the chuck laurie yeah
we are doing like a major reboot of the
show this year and we just got a bunch
of mom people too oh really yeah and
they were on two and a half men before
they were on isn't that crazy and then
yeah i just saw a thing last night on uh
the the toys that made us have you seen
that series on netflix yes well i've
watched like a piece of it but i'm like
oh i'll get in if i
i'll be obsessed yeah it's only the toys
obviously i mean maybe not obviously
maybe people like to broaden their
horizons but um i it's only the toys
that i loved growing up that i watched
the episodes of you know exactly so i'm
like i can relate to that but the
transformers one
i ch chuck laurie shows up in that
because apparently he
uh he came up with a song he was like a
songwriter yeah i didn't know that he
the we have a theme song at the
beginning of our show and he wrote it
with this amazing um like blues artist
named kedmo we we just re-recorded it he
was like so happy to be back in the
studio and picked up the guitar i know
right so fun do you guys talk about
because i know you're an incredible
singer i've i've seen you um do you do
you have you bonded over that well kind
of when we when we re-recorded the song
i'm singing it now for this next reboot
that's great so it was sort of like it
was like a whole other universe to be in
with him which he was like so happy to
be in it was fun it was great that's
cool yeah you probably can't talk too
much about the reboot i know it's called
oh negative which i thought was
it's
that would actually be positive no still
be positive okay but i like oh negative
that's a stupid joke stupid joke hey
why are you being funny yeah no no funny
baby i was attempting to be funny um
coming from broadway like you have
coming from great theater
uh to this space what what are the what
have you what challenges and what are
the like unexpected like oh this is kind
of cool
you know
this has been sort of a a wild
exploration of a form that is so
specific yeah it's not theater it's not
single cam
it's this kind of magical in between you
know
um
and jimmy burroughs direct the pilot and
i always thought he was you know he's
sort of like the master and he would
always
um
give me like little tips along the way
little things about the process like
just always keep your face on the page
when you're doing a run-through so that
everybody can really hear the line um
like don't worry about being off the
book you know like little things like
that like that's so important for the
problem you know that sounds like a
little thing to people but that that's
actually a really interesting tip
keep your face in the book yes and also
like this time is for the writers this
time is for the crew this there's
allocated times in the process of the
week for certain parts of the process
you know in the end
and then at one point it becomes yours
the actors but you kind of have to be
doing your work all along and then in
terms of like
how broad to be
it feels more akin to theater but i
still the way that you do in single cam
like try to figure out how far away the
camera is
yeah that's my shot like even though
there's three shots of you at the same
time
i mean
there is some sort of like a and then
always trying to it almost feels like
you're doing like a black box that's
sort of like yeah i bet i bet because
well have you guys been doing it to an
audience or is it a limited aisle no we
haven't had an audience this whole time
because of the chronovirus we had one
for the pilot
which was great i always wondered that
like how then do you
navigate the the timing like how do how
do you deal with because obviously you
have to leave some do they tell you to
leave
time for laughs well thankfully the crew
laughs sometimes which is great which is
a relief um and then also uh
there are times where we do
there's sort of like an unspoken like
inherent feel about where there will be
a laugh and where there won't be and
then occasionally we get surprised on
set and the crew will laugh at something
we didn't think it would get a laugh
but
i mean honestly i'm like waiting
chomping at the bit for i didn't two out
i didn't know i would feel that way
because i have never really known doing
a multicam without a knot you know with
an audience just that pilot yeah but i
just think it's like so helpful for the
like the magic of it you know we still
have the magic but it'll be fun to have
it back i bet yeah there's i guess
there's no substitute for
feeling that that energy like a play i
mean people listening might be this
might be like insider
inside baseball not insider baseball i
like insider baseball
it is totally insane
insider uh
it might be that for people but like
there is some
well describe that then for people who
might be unfamiliar with that feeling is
there a way to how would you articulate
like the the involvement of an audience
in
a a an acting piece
so i always feel like there's um
tig notaro explained it really
beautifully in um
that that documentary that they did on
her a couple years ago she said this
amazing thing about stand up and she
said there's the audience
there's you and then there's that space
in between
and like the three come together and i
sort of think of it as like the holy
spirit yes yeah and jesus god and the
holy spirit all come together
you know and it is sort of like that
beautiful energy and
that's sort of i think about it as like
a as a
as an energy shift and like a magic you
know there's like a spark in the air you
know the same way that like
anybody who's seen anything live even
like your kid's school performance or a
band that you saw in the back row
you got you were all a part of an event
in a moment in a space and place and
time and that is i think what sort of
captured even when you watch a sitcom
you're sort of like you were there on
tape night two
totally i bet i bet there was there's a
um and and conversely like when that's
missing like whether obviously the
audience isn't there but if they're just
not there in spirit if like uh an
audience that is less
involved how do i say this yeah you know
wednesday that night wednesday matinee
yeah
if you know you know but but really it's
just when they're not when they're there
their bodies are there
but you can't feel their it's a thing
you can just feel i i don't it's
intangible i guess but like it is so it
makes such a difference it must sound so
weird to people
listening who don't do this and
potentially alienating we're probably
losing a lot of listen here's a great
thing to just share with somebody who's
a an audience member is that you think
that we can't see you but we can
oh yes you know and we can feel you i
always try to and when i'm an audience
member i'm always like i try to open up
all my chakras
of love
um
there was once a wednesday matinee that
we did not all my chakras not all not
all of them
yeah
um there was a wednesday matinee that we
had once during you can't take it with
you and there was literally half of a
row of people asleep just literally half
a row they just felt real tired i'd love
to i would be tired too it's just hard
to get there and then another time
during a performance of legally blonde
there was an opera box you know there's
like a couple of them at the top
there was um a family eating a bucket of
chicken no what yes and it was fantastic
i loved that we could smell it everybody
was like where did they get it from like
there was like some chicken place down
the street somebody got some of these
sweet shows we were down with that uh
it's great it's also like it's such a
that's such a fun show i mean if it's
gonna happen in any show it's like it's
legally blonde and it's so so i love
that what it stands for it's like yeah
theater should be for everyone amen yes
that is like i think i'm actually sort
of
a little bummed out that the structure
financial structure of the theater
community especially broadway was not
re-evaluated during this time when we
could have re-evaluated it because it
needs to shift and it needs to totally
it shouldn't cost a million dollars to
load in a show and it shouldn't cost 65
minimum to sit at the back of the
theater i know i know i know it's true
in in the case of the ch the chicken
eaters
you know that's just like i always try
to weigh people's and i try to consider
people's intentions and in that case
it's like oh they didn't intend they
didn't know that that was potentially
disruptive and
you know they're just enjoying the show
with some chicken i was doing sylvia
which is a play about um yeah i played a
girl who's a really i played a dog dog i
played matthew broderick's dog and
there's a scene at the end of the play
it's like i love that play it's such a
sweet magical play and at the end of the
play the matthew broderick's character
tells me that he has to give me away to
another family and i have like a 10 page
freak out like i it's like epigenia you
know i'm like no
why don't you love me like
very funny
but to me very real so anyways we're
like a couple pages into the scene
and this lady's phone goes off and she's
probably in the fifth or sixth row
ring
ring
ring we're just we still we're still
going and i can see matthew in his eyes
like like oh god
and then then she picks it up no
allow
what's happening
full conversation
then the audience
literally starts yelling at her the
audience starts vocally yelling at
yelling
no this one man's very intense and it
was right after patti lupone had called
out that person yes in the audience yeah
it's my favorite people were like kind
of hot on it like and caught on calling
people out
it was a really time when people were
doing bad things with their phones in
the theater so she goes into the she
finally gets out into the side of the
of the theater could you see all this
happening
oh god and there was like a vestibule
and she thought she was outside of it
she was you could still hear her
i first didn't get to hurt and it was so
loud and the audience was like whoa
so then
matthew did this like really funny thing
where he stopped the scene he walked to
the edge of the stage and he told
everybody he he was like he started
doing mime work he didn't speak he just
wanted his hands to like calm everybody
down the audience got quiet and stopped
and then he pointed to her and then he
did like a baseball sign of like you're
out of here and everybody clapped
he still didn't say anything and that's
amazing then he just looked at me
like with a blank face and i went well
how did you not laugh i mean laughing
and then i said i guess we should go
back and he was like he nodded still
didn't say anything a pro what a pro
and i said where should we go back from
and he went
still and i i think we're gonna and i
told them i said you won't go back from
and i told like okay let's go back to
this page this line and we set reset
ourselves and then we did the rest of
the play
okay both of us were like you know both
when we got off stage we obviously
couldn't talk about it both of us were
concerned it was so wild to answer the
phone like that it was so courageous
something must be wrong with her we
convinced ourselves that there was like
a family emergency right you know we and
we both just decided that that's
that she had to answer her phone well it
was so wild that both of us thought that
yeah just just to be okay with the world
literally to be okay with that happening
yeah i still believe that to this day go
well i there had to have been something
that she need to answer that phone for
that lady probably thought she was being
who knows discreet or she was just i
don't know
and then i heard about a story of
somebody going on stage during um i
can't remember what play it is but there
were like electrical outlets on the um
set and they climbed up on the stage it
was a show at the booth they climbed on
the stage and plugged their phone in in
the electrical outlet to charge you
what did people do what did they do on
stage i think a crew person like one of
the crew members had to come out be like
uh that's not real and you can't get on
the stage i think the usher is probably
too old like get off the stage
another thing i love is the um the
people who are overactive it's like
there's a lot of
also when there's a um a funny laugh
oh there's nothing worse yeah there's
nothing worse than like a really funny
laugh and you're like oh don't break
don't break don't laugh at that person
laughing they're just enjoying it
um funny laugh and then also um
i haven't done wicked in like 12 years
it's been a long time but
long many hounds ago when i played
glenda every once in a while
a little kid would laugh at something
that nobody else would laugh at oh
that's something and like so you know
there were a couple times where i just
would break because this was like we all
have to acknowledge the magic of that
yes totally so sweet was a.r gurney
forgive me if this is insensitive was is
he alive he passed recently um the last
couple years but he was with us for the
play and it was that's what i thought
the play actually was done originally
off-broadway and sarah jessica she did
played sylvia um so that was kind of a
neat thing and sort of full circle for
everybody there was something kind of
fun about that and she also
matthew and her were not married yet
they were like and they weren't newly
dating but they um he had a dog at the
time that she sort of like based her
sylvia oh that's so funny wow that's so
cool the result starts at fun like
little like
magical allegory moments that while we
were working on it
[Music]
the older i get the more i appreciate
and need sleep i love it it's also
healthy you need it you need it so
here's a good way to get it with plus
cbd it has helped me i've been using it
me too i know both have to use plastic
daily use of plus cbd sleep gummies get
you the rest you need so you can wake up
feeling focused and refreshed now that
was written but i also agree with that i
have slept a lot better with these
gummies it's formulated by a team of
medical experts and doctors
uh and it's an award-winning cbd
combined with melatonin magnolia bark
and lemon balm all plus cbd products are
third party tested and fully traceable
from seed to shelf so you can be assured
you're getting the highest quality hemp
cbd on those days you just need a
positive push plus cbd is the perfect
go-to product the pure ingredients can
help you reduce stress alleviate
soreness and improve your overall sleep
who doesn't want all those things plus
cbd sleep gummies are the perfect
bedside support for those sleepless
nights i can attest to that 100 now
here's a fun little addition to the cbd
gummies the reserve collection gummies
uh this is a life is short exclusive
reserve collection is a specially
curated blend of full-spectrum
cannabinoids that's rich and bold
[Music]
the reserve collection gummies with 25
milligrams of cbd and a fun part 2.5
milligrams of thc you can sleep better
tonight by visiting plus cbd oil.com
that is plus cbd oil.com and enter promo
code long for 40 off your order that's
code long
plus cbd oil dot com for forty percent
off your order
in the early two thousands millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
hello
[Music]
you've hello so much great theater i saw
you and you can't take it with you which
i think that's where i met you briefly i
think so too i think yeah yeah um and
what what is it like when you
when you're looking for the next thing
i've always wondered that when you're
because you're at like the the top of
the theater
food chain sort of so you you strikes me
that you would have your pick of things
to do
how do you decide what to do because
it's also such a crazy commitment those
things
i mean that is the sweetest compliment
ever i don't i i feel like i'm never
feeling like that i'm always like what's
happening is there a part for me oh
really that's for real well yeah and
then um you know
after you can't take it with you um
like the the next couple shows that i
got to do they just sort of were kismet
you know and i always sort of think
that's the way that the theater sign up
kind of works out it's sort of there's
an alchemy to it and magic and
um sylvia just sort of was an accident
you know they wanted to do it and then
um it was sort of a match and the timing
worked out and it was like it all just
kind of came together and then the same
thing with sunday in the park with
george um they were gonna do this
concert of it and then
um i knew jake gyllenhaal was doing it i
remember telling my husband like oh man
that's like the part of a lifetime
that's my dream role of dreams but
they'll never hire me i don't was your
husband like
wait who who's is jake gyllenhaal was he
at all concerned
well then when they called and they were
like they want you to play dot i
literally i mean it's gonna make me tear
up now i can't believe that they were
like
trusted me with the role but um it's
magic i imagine though if you win a tony
which you did for you can't take with
you i'm not telling you telling the
audience i'm sure you won a tony in case
you forgot uh
there's i put a unicorn next to it
though because i'm always like this is
crazy
that doesn't really change anything
psychologically it doesn't like
give you a boost of confidence or like
oh yeah i'm kind of in this new
category or whatever
i feel like you've seen so many
actors too in your life where
we always you're like oh that person's
never looking for a job and then they
are you know like totally the
the tops of the tops people that you
would never think would be hustling it's
still like
after all these years
they're a legend and they're still
trying to like just what's my next job
so that's oh my god you know like really
in that head space you're like oh man
it's true you know my friend was just
telling me a great story she was working
with her ran into had a head up in kind
of an in-depth conversation with
sylvester stallone and he had this
energy that was similar to what you just
described it was like i'm trying to do
that you know i'm working on that you
know talking about the hustle and like
yeah if the agents are like you know and
and how he can't get the thing made and
how
these pretty you know how it's a grind
and this was not that long ago so it was
like
and and then he did he revived in order
to like kind of keep working and keep
keep doing it he brought rocky back he
brought ram all his old properties but i
i it really struck me that that um
you know i think that's a perfect
example
of of what you just described which is
like
your
actors are like carnies you know there's
this carny spirit and like i guess
you're right you're always kind of
hustling and that stallone thing really
struck me that like [ __ ] even sylvester
stallone still has to like hustle no and
he still wants to which is also
part of it like that's the chuck laurie
thing yes and like linda lavin yesterday
um
she
is back for the season so she was
telling me they just got a house and
she's going to get furniture and and
she's like you got any extra pots and
pans that's the only thing because
because i just had a bunch of my stuff
from new york moved and i was like oh my
gosh i've been going through boxes
uh-huh and i we i said linda isn't it
wild i just it makes me laugh that
you're doing this and i and i said i
looked at my husband recently and said
how many times are we going to do this
in our life like move across the country
and like go do we need this air purifier
anymore you know and
she laughed and then i looked at her and
i go i guess we're just gypsies
yeah it's true yeah baby yeah you know
like that's awesome yeah i know
something about that
oh i love well it's it's part of the
i i think in a way it's it's part of
what drives people to do that to do
there's that's the spirit that you kind
of need to to
pursue this life because it's not just
like enjoying acting a lot of people you
know it's one thing to like acting but
it's the
to actually pursue it for a living is uh
requires a certain
i think it requires a certain makeup it
requires a certain spirit and maybe the
gypsy spirit is is a part of that gypsy
spirit and then also like kind of goes
back to that thing we were talking about
like you know chuck laurie could totally
be like in hawaii full-time
but um
he cares about the artistry of it you
know what i mean same way that like um
oh my gosh james earl jones is a great
example of like a true artist when we
were doing a can't take it with you he
used to come in on thursdays him and my
husband will come in at like two o'clock
in the afternoon and just read othello
parts of the play that he
wanted to like explore more and feel
like he never really got i mean and my
husband was like this is the best thing
that ever happened in the universe is
like the gift of a lifetime
um oh my god
what
was he in the hopes of maybe putting it
up or just was it just exercise
just an exercise um
and my husband was in the play too and
so they they had just had a really sweet
relationship and they both loved
shakespeare so much and they you know
somehow came up and it came around
and
he also would play during the run in a
really special way but he would warn you
he'd be like i'm working on something in
act two
uh when you come in to bring me cookies
so i'm just gonna
i'll surprise you so do i'm just warning
you i'm working on something and if no
and he didn't have the best hearing and
if you said a line and he couldn't hear
it
um
he would just go what and you would just
say the line again
because he couldn't hear his cue i love
that yeah he was literally what makes it
real
real well what
yeah isn't that novel
uh only the legends do that
i was watching usual suspects again
because i had been hearing people were
saying about it that like i i just shot
a uh a movie in bulgaria and and for
some reason
it it kept coming up and the director
and the db about a bunch of the crew
were saying like yeah it doesn't really
hold up they were talking about how it
didn't and i remember loving that movie
and so i rewatched it and it i i thought
it held i loved it again i continued to
love it but there was there's a scene in
it that that just reminded me of where
benicio del toro is
um because that none of that was on this
in the script with him mumbling and like
uh he and he said something in the jail
cell he was like
i i i flip you i flipping for real you
know something like that and kevin
pollock it's off camera he goes
what it's so real it's such a real
moment and he just makes him repeat it
and there's something
it's tr i love that they left it in um i
love that james earl jones would do that
it's the most pure
form of acting it's like i said
something and i can't hear you i'm like
listening to you it's so great i love
that they he would do that i love that
yeah amazing master master class every
day master class yeah uh your oh your
husband must have been on like cloud
nine like doing that oh yeah i mean he
got to like he got to be iago on
thursday afternoons with james jones as
othello
that is so cool
that is so sweet um
do you know why they're rebooting
is it a simple answer why they're
rebooting be positive i think that the
you know when we we got through the
kidney transplant we always knew we
needed to go a different direction oh
yeah so he got staying there yeah we got
to the end of the season and he got his
kidney and he had to get it we got you
know we had to get it at pumpkin
right and then um
and so the direction that we're going
now is really lovely and still about
being positive
and but really about um
taking care of each other which i think
is absolutely um an imperative theme
right now
and you know putting others before
yourself
um so that's kind of the direction we're
going in which is fun and
cool some some really like amazing uh
legendary actors are coming on so that's
fun yeah oh how well yeah i know
you know your background obviously we've
been talking about uh a very rich
theater background but tom is is such a
he's such an improv guy to me he he's
he's so he's so obviously he's one of
the best um
i've seen him at ucb and stuff he's just
so like quick and
it is there have they formatted the show
so that he's able to you're both able to
utilize that gift like are you able to
improv at all on that show or is it is
it just like a typical like most all
multi-cams where it's scripted heavily
scripted we're heavily scripted but kind
of you know the magic of multicam is
that things
happen in the moment and we get to play
and you know it's he had a moment
yesterday
yesterday we were sitting there we were
waiting for the take to start
um
and somehow we lamented about how much
we miss like an audience
he just he looked at me anyway
you know like
his his world of improv which is like
the long form of it we kind of get to do
like baby short form right now you know
like every once in a while we get a
dollop of daisy that's cool yeah yeah
but i felt for him because that is like
oh man it's going to be a minute because
that is that means body sticky bodies in
her room i know
i thought for sure whatever i mean this
is this is just too depressing but but
like i thought for sure now
me too so many people say they have
celiac disease they're like i have
celiac and they say it casually and i
know that people who really do have it
it's not something you say casually
because it's like a heavy duty thing i
love that you're asking about this i
could talk about the gut microbiome for
years
what do you take
what's your regimen my dream is to
really like just do podcasts about the
gut microbiome you know i could
literally talk about it um well so i
like to say like when i go to a
restaurant hi i have celiac disease so
i'm gluten free for real which does not
denounce anybody who is eating no no we
don't want to offend because a
gluten-free diet is i think actually
really necessary and healthy for many
people's got microbiomes more than they
know it i think like if you don't have
celiac disease there's a great
possibility that many people in this
country probably have a gluten allergy
so that is like a totally real thing
totally believe in it but
if um my husband does not have celiac
but he eats mostly gluten free if he
eats a bite of a soft pretzel he's not
going to puke and like
feel like he is a flu for three days and
get a weird little fever some people
everybody's response is different i have
a really good friend who she gets a
migraine right away that's the way her
symptoms surface my mother-in-law
actually just found out she had celiac
disease which i've been kind of being
for years been like i think that you
should get checked um and she has it but
one of her big symptoms is rashes
everywhere which is really common
um
wow so it's like an allergy really to
gluten it's like a intense allergy can't
i mean it can manifest that as a symptom
but celiac disease is when it's an
autoimmune disorder and
it's basically gluten attacks the villi
in your lower intestine
and so they lay flat and they should be
standing up so that they can filter the
food and help digest and simulate
disease makes them lay flat and it's you
know your immune system lives in your
gut
so when um
when it's active and you're eating
gluten then your immune system is all
off and it's tacking itself and
oh my god so so it's it's really just
glu i mean if so you're able to
avoid all of those symptoms just by not
eating gluten i'm not saying just like
it's easy but just like that's how you
do it it's like the best autoimmune
disease to have because you don't eat
gluten and you're good
that's true
so do you have to take any other
supplements like any probiotics or
anything yeah so usually when you get
the diagnosis then it's like another
couple years of sort of like being like
i don't you feel great like the first
couple months you're like i feel so much
better i feel better immediately and
then um
then it's like
i always think that it takes another
couple years for your gut to heal itself
and for you to figure out what's going
on with your gut a lot of people have
celiac disease have like candida
um which is like an overgrowth of yeast
in the lower intestine and a lot of
people have sibo which is like an
overgrowth of good stuff in the small
intestine like that's an embed you're
just out of balance you've like got
permeability which is like the lining of
the gut is thin that that was me
um
and so you're just you're not quite
right for a couple years and then you
try to get the gut back back in balance
how did you discover that emily like
were you when you were a kid were you
did it when did it kind of show up
physiologically well i farted a lot and
i'm kidding that's what i'm looking for
um well finally the good stuff right the
good stuff um
actually yesterday i kept looking at
thomas and i was like do you think if i
farted the mic would pick it up like
it's always like i
i've had that i've done that
arithmetic in my head before
i know i there i think i don't know how
many people can relate to that but i
remember i've done that i mean you know
when you have like a there's a it's in
you there's like a there's like a it's
not a fart yet because it hasn't come
out
i guess
when would it become a like it's a gas
bubble it's a gas bubble that it hasn't
descended and then you're like if i try
to push it out now i may [ __ ] my pants
you don't want it
it'll be loud if i push it'll be like a
bugle oh my god
but yeah but
nothing better
but we went to that well so celiac
disease is actually like i have the
genes for it but i don't think the gene
was turned on until like late high
school
so you can either have it show up as a
kid if the gene gets turned on when
you're a kid and though
if your kid is not thriving so
that means they're not very tall or
they're little and they're you know
you're like why aren't they growing
that's usually a symptom
lots of stomach problems are the
symptoms but for me i think it happened
i had a big round of antibiotics at the
end of high school and that's when my
stomach started going wrong
you know and everybody just goes you
have ibs oh yeah you're just activated
all the time and yeah your stomach my
stomach would blow up like i would look
five minutes pregnant oh my god i had
these epic belches like everybody on
broadway knew every sound man on
broadway would be like i've never heard
a little girl belch like that and then
when i oh my when i went gluten-free
they completely stopped
you're cute that's amazing yeah oh my
god
and you were um
i want to know about your family so
quick but there's no quick way to do it
you grew up in a big how big was your
family um i have a brother and sister
who are ten and eight years younger than
me so there were three of us which is
super fun and then i had tons of cousins
and
you know i grew up in denver colorado
um and we'd go to the mountains a lot i
know how to
you are i love to fish do you do you
i love fishing would you fly fishing you
do sometimes not very good we just went
with my dad and i like had been for so
long that i did weirdly did it with a
bobber which makes no sense but i did it
no
no uh oh fly fishing with a bobber you
mean i mean it was kind of a weird way
to do it my dad that is a weird winner
my dad literally was like i can't
believe you actually caught the fish
today
that's amazing i do love fishing with
the bobber because i love looking at i
love having something to focus on we do
you know and i love how exciting is it
when it moves a little bit and um
god that i made the mistake of putting i
caught a big uh it was a largemouth and
which on the lake i live on you you
can't eat those because they they pick
up a lot of like the crap in the water
the toxins and stuff um
and especially the bigger ones and so i
quickly took a picture with it and and
put it back it was like a quick catch
and release and
i just got an instagram and i've put the
photo on instagram and
i got and i had been caught i had been
like aware enough because i know
because of the changing climate and
people's sensitivities and like i didn't
want to
offend anyone and i got so much [ __ ]
from your torturing animals and like and
i released it and i made i was so clear
to say that was a real lesson in like
social navigation oh my god social media
yeah i know isn't it wild take a picture
of a fish it's just and also you let it
go you know oh yeah also
people have been fishing since the day
one so it's sort of part of the circle i
don't know how i mean the shame it's the
shame it's the like outrage
um speaking of you're playing paula
jones how cool this is it's a great
segue because monica lewinsky was the
first person to be bullied on the
internet
right publicly shamed yeah on that
platform that now every now everyone's
being bullied on the internet oh yeah um
it's true right she really was for real
that's like sort of her
purpose in life now is to sort of bring
help and awareness to
bullying on the internet just that's
right wild i know and it i i think it's
so cool how she has kind of reclaimed
her story and
what happened to her so i can't i'm so
fascinated by this um
uh how how they're gonna what their take
is on it and and obviously you probably
can't say too much and we literally
don't have the time to talk too much
about it but um
were you aware of paula jones like are
you
were you too young at the time to to
remember when it was happening i was
super aware of the story i knew for some
reason i think it's because i would
watch late night tv like
appropriately as a child i like conan
o'brien was my hero and i thought i was
gonna marry him someday i literally
would like journal about marrying conan
o'brien with paula jones had you ever
ever played like a real person um this
was my first real person that i had well
this is my first really the real person
that was um really famous and uh
had been in the public eye one of the
things about paula jones is i think
people will have sort of like a
caricature of her in their mind and i
certainly did because i i actually knew
so much about the story way more than i
realized i did really from from watching
late night talk shows because they were
so ruthless to these women the media
coverage of these women was just like
horrific so
um i watched a lot of footage of her
because i felt like it was important
to make sure that i could
really
make her as authentic as i could but
also
it couldn't feel like an impression and
it couldn't feel like a caricature i
feel like that's what all of us sort of
felt like in our journeys with these
characters because it's pretty we're
living in an era that's really close to
the air in which it happened
so it's fresh in our memories these
people are fresh and also yes you want
to humanize them you want to humanize
them yeah so
um
i did a lot of uh dialect work um i did
a lot of movement work
and then oh wow cause she's where's she
from again she's from arkansas yeah
she's from london arkansas and um her
physicality really changed throughout
the years because when she first was
pushed into the public eye she
had
was not prepared to be in any sort of
media situation and as the time went by
there were operatives
from the conservative community who kind
of came in and gave her coaching and
helped her as the trial got bigger and
bigger so you can literally see in her
posture like she sits up straighter
you know
yeah it's fascinating yeah wow like the
karl rove and those guys they they like
coached her well it wasn't it was more
of a star who is it uh
he wasn't involved in paula jones as
sort of wing of the story but people
like ann coulter and um george conway
were secretly working on her legal team
they were called the elves so they're a
part of the story um and then there was
this wonderful
well
judith light does a outrageously magical
job of portraying this woman named susan
carpenter macmillan who was
part of the right-wing machine and kind
of came in and was swooped in and was
like a legal legal liaison for paula um
and helped her with her clothes and
got her a new haircut and
coached her for her press stuff and it
was all sort of part of this
coalition of people trying to get
bill clinton out of office and figuring
out how they could impeach him but then
it all
all of the monica lewinsky stuff
connected back to the paula jones case
but it was a way that they could figure
out how to get him to lie under oath
it's really fascinating how it all came
about and he still did you know he did
he lied
and you know that feeling of when you're
lying is my whole body tries to reject
it i i have a i'm a terrible liar i'm
not saying this as like a humble brag
we're like i'm so honest but like i just
have physically like it manifests in a
way that like i have a hard time
lying but i've done it i'm not saying
like i'm i can't imagine doing it in
that
on that stage you know the the
what that must have felt like what that
must have how you can
psychologically how do you how do you
prepare yourself to do that how do you
do it how do you do that
well and also
it was
one of the things that's i'm not
defending bill clinton i'm not defending
anything like that but
i'm i'm not even like i i i'm not even
criticizing it
i'm like
curious about how it's done yeah i think
from my perspective when we go deeper
into this story it's
it just feels so private like there's
been a lot of questions like when we do
interviews and stuff they're like why
isn't there any sex you know why aren't
you showing the sex and
they always have such a great answer
that sarah burgess the writer is always
like we saw we heard about everything
in such great detail that ken starr
report has written like 50 shades of
grey like we know
we don't need to rehash it you don't
need to see it you know what happened
and basically my point of saying that is
it was so private
but i don't think he thought in a
million i don't think he got in a
million gazillion years that there was
somebody taping monica lewinsky talking
privately about their moments together
and right monica surely never thought
that any of it would ever come out ever
oh my god yeah it's true it's like yeah
it's true it must be like
that those acts are always you know for
your whole life you're
there there's private i mean there's a
privacy that that extends to even family
member or like people close to you in
your life like no one knows about that
stuff like
um
i must have just felt
impossible
for people to know that like the
it that's so true it like i think it was
that
it also was
monica lewinsky says over and over and
over again that it was
um
like she was
uh she agreed like it was um why am i
blanking on the word where you're like i
was in it too complicit oh i was
complacent
what's up what's the um consent
it was consensual so
you've forgotten the word because you've
been married for so long i know
it's you don't need it you know
seriously
that's like the most important word
right now i have a son at the playground
i'm like don't play with anybody without
their consent
yeah right
yeah it's like it's it always reminds me
when homer simpson's like uh he forgets
the word for spoon and he's like honey i
need a thing to dig ice cream
yeah i know uh man brain farts
happening more and more i wish that i
was actually farting though it's just oh
would have been nice if i could have
landed one for you but um yeah it's uh
i find that to be like it's so wild that
it how happened you know and it also the
line of it it does i totally agree with
you and also
i think that it's another uh comment on
like our political system is that that's
just something that we've just come
accustomed to is people in public office
just lie a lot to like protect ourselves
and to protect protect protect their um
constituents
and to protect you know there's a lack
of trust there's a lack of honesty and
that's also like another theme in the
show you know just like yeah we've all
come i mean now it's like it's just
become second nature but but but to lie
so bl to lie about something so like you
said private
um
is i guess a different that's a whole
new
threshold it's not like lying about some
political move it's a [ __ ] it's like
sex also culturally we're not where we
are now so it didn't like
i don't know if he would lie now you
know what i mean
i don't know what would happen now maybe
he would i have no idea it's so
complicated that's why it's going to
make such a great i can't wait to watch
this show and and also
you know in light of how like you said
how much has changed and and um
it just sounds like such an interesting
character to get into especially
considering how much
she had to perform and change and um
just all just the makeup and the
the hair and stuff wearing those clothes
must have been i mean actors fantasy you
know when you get to transform into
another human it's like
such a
it's like it was like christmas but also
i'm interested to see how people kind of
respond to paula jones because they
most people in our current culture and
anybody who lived through that era they
have no idea that
her motives were really pushed by the
people around her and that she was you
know like her super objective was just
to please her husband
it was literally like
i'm not really it was only to try to
please her husband to make her husband
happy
oh my god who plays the husband um uh
taryn killen who is amazing he's oh my
god friend of the show yeah oh we love
love isn't he the best he's so funny
best such a magical human all we do is
talk about disney world into our
disneyland and yes are we kids
interested in the same stuff and his
wife is just the best in the club
she's playing ann coulter and she's also
she is believable both of them are oh my
god kobe's
and culture she's unbelievable both oh i
bet them are so so good
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
if you've ever wondered about
well
anything sign up for one dream that's
w-o-n-d-r-i-u-m
it's a platform where you can go and
learn things you can kind of learn about
anything if you are one of these people
who has wondered then you should do
yourself a very big favor
and sign up for one dream it is our
favorite streaming service and we're
pretty confident that you're gonna love
it too i took one called pioneering
skills for everyone modern homesteading
where i learned how to make pickles and
i've become quite the pickler pickleman
i'm pretty sure you can find anything
you want there are so many options to
choose from i took one on psychology
i've always been curious what was it
called it was called intro to psychology
i can remember that i think everyone
could benefit from learning a little bit
more about the components of happiness
or how to manage stress
uh and this program really digs into all
of that i should check that one out i
dug into it with one dream all of their
videos are academically comprehensive
they're relentlessly entertaining and
they're led by engaging experts we know
you'll love one dream just like we do so
we have arranged a special limited time
offer for our listeners a free month
trial of unlimited access to get this
offer sign up now through our special
url onerium.com
long that's
r
w-o-n-d-r-i
u m
dot com slash long
hello hello again
[Music]
what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say oh uh your go-to rainbow
rainbow
uh in because i i normally only use that
in the context of um
anything to do with the uh
the the gay community
oh yeah lgbtq plus magic is magic for me
all the time i love a rainbow it makes
me feel all the feels and i feel like
i'm constantly like
i want everything to be magical
hey look at this
yes
oh i love it yeah a unicorn goes a long
way
time to be a unicorn my friend got me
this kind of as a joke and i love it i i
uh great i use all the time okay um
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play and why uh
running because um i my mom loves it
i've never liked it so it would be nice
to do that with her but it won't happen
my my knees are like no thank you
really that's like the sweetest answer i
think we've ever had for that
you you um she runs all the time good
for her
yeah she she was a cross-country and
track coach when i was a kid and now she
doesn't do that anymore but she always
but she's a great runner and i just
really don't like it
so fish so you prefer fishing obviously
what what um what's the biggest fish
you've ever caught
oh my gosh well sometimes those like
ponds that you go to where they like
they get really big because they you
know what i mean they just get bigger
like they're like yeah that's crazy but
yes i probably like carp like a like a
footer i've caught like a foot long yeah
yeah foot
a footer footer and a halfer
um
yeah if you could have one snack food
for the rest of your life what would it
be oh
well croissants and soft pretzels
because they can't figure out how to
make them gluten free so someday and
sometimes i dream about eating them but
they're just not really nobody's really
done it right gluten-free oh
right that makes sense croissants [ __ ]
i shouldn't tell you this i just i in
bulgaria there's in sofia bulgaria by
the way sophia bulgaria
is a magical place i would never have
thought um i i loved it so much but the
croissants there were
and they would inject like a vanilla
pudding into them like a congratulations
i'm sorry
that's awful there was a guy one of the
producers on it was a um orthodox jew
and and uh he i used to talk about the
food all because i love food and he'd be
like thanks a lot justin he was always i
always forgot that he wasn't able to eat
you know uh and i just did it with you
even though i didn't forget i was just
being
selfish
what's your um
so you say you have kids i've i've been
almost five-year-old
oh cute okay what a great age what well
so this is the perfect time to ask you
this question
what um
what movie were you or are you really
hoping to
introduce them to like you can't wait to
show them this we've been talking about
ferris bueller like some classic from
your youth
well we have he's gotten to seize a lot
of our favorites um
but we tried indiana jones like six
months ago and it just was too early so
were we too early yeah we need like the
beginning was too scary so i feel like
one more
one more a year and like then we'll move
on to the harrison ford uh you know
that legacy i saw that i saw that
recently it is raiders of just the
beginning of raiders the lost stars and
the skeleton shots and like it's
when alfred molina gets like
killed with brother it's dog we have to
wait we started and we went surely and
he was yeah
so i think that's that's going to be a
fun one
that's fun well apparently indiana chose
the temple of doom not to go on a little
nerd tributary uh that was one of the
movies i think that in gremlins were the
two movies that like
that created the pg-13 rating because
spielberg was so wanted them to they
were originally rated r this the temple
of doom and he appealed he like went
through this like lengthy appeal with
the mpa and um so they created a whole
new rating for that uh right
yeah uh okay um but uh
i tried to show uh my friend's little
kid who was like three or four the dark
crystal because i was like oh kids movie
i had it there there
was so
dark for me but the kid was like into it
was like i said you're not scared no
you know i was like holy god it's yeah
really dark um
what is your go-to karaoke song you must
be amazing at karaoke oh my gosh um no
more tears
you know barbra streisand and uh yeah
and donna summer i sing both hearts oh
my god
really yeah it's weird oh jesus that's
hilarious is joe as your husband joe
right joe yeah is he no is he a good no
no no not
that's not that that's not where god
gave him his gifts
so you didn't meet on a musical it was
you did you meet on a play as
no we didn't ever we didn't work
together until you can't take it with
you and we'd already been together for
like we were like oh is this going to go
okay i hope we still have each other
afterwards yeah we were already married
but um yeah but
he's really good at acting he's really
good at i've been he's really good at
shakespeare
too uh-huh oh cool well he must oh god
he must be climbing the walls
um yeah who was your very first
celebrity crush
hey
uh i'm gonna say conan because that was
the first person that i was like
oh
like it's a 10 year old being like hold
on i'm going to marry him having weird
fans got married in some day
no i again
this has been been a common thing um if
you had to get a tattoo uh i don't know
if you have any but if you wanted
another one where would you what would
you get i don't have any but i guess i
would like do my i guess i'd do jack's
name somewhere that's my little boy's
name i'd do jack
or maybe his birthday somewhere or or my
best friend always used to say walt
disney's signature on his ass that's
great
oh that's great that is great a really
like innocent thing i'm like that's
great um if you had to get a tattoo i
asked you that what's your favorite
fruit my favorite fruit ooh berries
berry medley raspberries blueberry
strawberries thank you
yes they're incredible antioxidants
who
would you want to play you you're
talking about paula jones you're playing
paula jones who would you want to play
you in your um your biopic um judy
holliday from the from from heaven she
can come from the grave and complain me
okay okay
she's gonna be so excited
he's like i gotta roll
um in the mortal world uh who who's your
favorite muppet
oh
good question
i mean
i have to say miss piggy
but i feel like miss piggy and the
kermit combo are my favorite
yeah
yeah that is um
dynamic oh i love you guys so much i
love fozzie i was just doing fozzie bear
for my um
little nephew we have a little fozzie
it's so fun to do those it must be so
fun to have a five-year-old and do those
characters
you guys both must be such good
parents that way and just like
entertaining he doesn't like him when i
sing though would you stop singing stop
it mom
yeah and audra mcdonald has the same
thing with her little girl which makes
me feel a lot better
oh my god my brother damien's going to
be so flattered that i'm comparing him
in any way to you both but he the same
thing with him like he he loves musical
he he loves to sing around the house and
his kids are like
it's same thing stop it dad
yeah and he doesn't have
nearly as good a voice sorry damian um
what is your go-to pizza topping
um pepperoni half cheese half
half cheese half extra cheese yeah like
half extra cheese half pepperoni
oh gotcha yes uh and and was there a
place in new york that you really missed
like what was your go-to pizza place oh
my gosh well when i could eat gluten it
was like joe's and then there was this
amazing gluten-free pizza place called
soda casa in brooklyn that was awesome
oh man um i'm sure there's some in l.a
uh
sure find some larchmont largemouth yeah
fresh brothers makes good gluten free
pizza loose first there's some good ones
um dogs or cats do you prefer
i love a dog i have a dog but i love a
cat uh beetles are rolling stones oh
beetles but i love the rolling stones
too and if you could hear a beatles song
right now like what what is what comes
to mind hey jude was playing when my
little boy was born ah how great um
emily i have totally taken advantage of
your kindness thank you this was so fun
i it was too funny
you're the best i'm so grateful i got to
spend time with you i can't wait to like
have a dinner with you and taryn
i would love it i would love that and
kobe
i can't wait to see the reboot because
because i you and thomas are two of my
favorites i i can't wait thanks pal yeah
thank you and enjoy it have a good one
enjoy chocolate i'm gonna go put on my
hair and my pants now okay see you later
okay you okay good oh you were not
wearing pants this whole time i should
have told people that um i i actually
have not oh
that's funny oh man aren't you gonna
kind of miss this this
yeah i'm pulling a jeffrey tube in hey
yeah okay i'm leaving you guys okay
thank you so much
[Music]
so
that's
i don't know it was such like an
unnecessarily ditzy impression of her
well she placed it really well yeah but
now that just happened
that's that's a little like someone that
reminds me of someone else who is that
uh well you did it was a little perky
sink a little drew
yes yes i'm like yes yes um
yeah but she was uh half
similarly to drew so fun to talk to
yeah fun fun to connect with and um you
seem like you really enjoy talking to
her well i'm really hit it off she's a
real theater
maven you're good with theater people
whether they're
theater women or theater men yes i'm
good with all theater genders yeah
because it's it's also how we grew up i
mean our mother was a theater actress
and i grew up around people like she
seemed like someone mom was friends well
mom would
she's someone that mom would love if
either of us were like this is uh your
new daughter-in-law
i'm sure she would yeah she would be
psyched she would she said not that
she's not psyched no no no i didn't mean
to say yeah yeah
any of our
potential daughter-in-laws um
but yeah she she should be oh yeah cause
it's that [ __ ] up there with like anna
klumsky yes you know yes totally but
she's there's an ease and effervescence
to to those people and um
those people i don't mean to like also
you're one of those people by the way no
you're in that community i don't mean to
both stereotype and brag about myself
well you can talk about that community i
think because you're part of it
that's right i'm allowed to say make a
generalization make theater people jokes
because you're a theater person yes i
can make nerd jokes i can make
white people jokes what do you think
that's jokes that's probably you know
cis jokes are so funny there's a wealth
of cis jokes
um is that the community you feel most a
part of theater no really no no because
what other group of people do you feel
closer to that's a good i see i would
say theater for you you think yeah
because it is a tight-knit community
you've been i guess so doing it for a
long time a lot of your friends do
theater i don't think i feel that part
that much a part of any community like i
was going to say like well the
nomad
social nomad well like i love animals
and stuff i love like reptiles and stuff
like like do you think you're more part
of the herpetology community
i like i identify more with that
community really than theater community
you do yeah huh interesting no you
wouldn't think because it doesn't matter
what i think it's it's how you identify
well maybe not you know i have met some
herpetology but i don't want to alienate
people i don't want to say anything
negative about the her community but i
have gone to some of those like shows
those like
you know reptile and amphibian like
trade shows and um
some characters that those yeah though
you could say the same thing
i
i guess what i'm focusing now maybe too
much on is the extremes in in those
communities you know the extreme version
of communities is hard i'm trying i've
said it so many times in the last year
and each time you say your eyes bug out
a little bit and i i ramp up to it
let's stop talking and that's why it's
hard to be um that shout out in the
beginning to the community theater yes
was hard for me
uh anyway that was fun speaking of
community theater oh man that was fun um
sarah yes fan of the show
shorty she showed up showed up from
orlando
she was so sweet and we're so grateful
that she came all that way and uh and
you'll remember her from her letter a
couple weeks ago where she said she was
taking a gap year and and traveling
around she was going to vegas and so she
was watching in the audience she had
traveled all the way up
so shout out to sarah thank you for
coming and thanks
for everyone else for coming to you that
was a really fun night
saw
that was pretty intense yeah it was
really great and and we really
appreciate it and and again like um
the strangest part of it is like the uh
seeing people laugh at
these sometimes very juvenile jokes
seeing like older some older people
there yeah laughing maybe in spite of
themselves that balanced out moments
where i
thought people might laugh when they
didn't yeah and that feeling wasn't so
great
that feeling will always be i imagine
pretty difficult yeah i know it's just
like crickets
i know
it is it's weird it's unlike anything
i've ever i was like ringing my hands
during the first two scenes which aren't
the funniest um there's not like a lot
of comedy in those first two scenes yeah
but but it was such a relief when people
got into it and they seemed to so it was
such a relief those seconds go by like
hours we were saying the other night
like it was like for whom the bell tolls
it was like each second was like
when people aren't laughing at this
thing you made anyway thank you to
everyone yes but back to analie ashford
speaking of laughter and speaking of uh
talking about seeing things in front of
a live audience oh yeah a lot of theater
stories a lot of funny audience stories
she told about i love that stuff i do
too like maybe the theater community too
have you ever seen the
uh patti lupone yes scolding that's
amazing i am more of a theater guy you
got to get into impeachment
lots of for one thing lots of friends
the show on it oh that right yeah beanie
feldstein kobe is kobe stone
karen killem's kobe smulders uh i met
ann coulter once um and i've seen lucky
uh she came to my college when i was
there um
and what was she like
i i gotta say she was very cool yeah
yeah she was like very easy to talk to
and like cool like i don't mean this
please if you're like don't be offended
though this is not a political statement
like
divorcing this from anything political
just as a personality i also think it's
cool that she goes on those roasts and
like
allows people to like say that
yeah and she goes on bill maher and
she's like always the conservative voice
yeah and they just come after i know and
she can take it [ __ ] brave yeah again
regardless of you don't just say it
again yeah i get it but like it's pretty
courageous yeah
but well anyway most importantly friend
of the show kobe smulders mm-hmm
perfect impressions i i saw it i saw
some stuff like uncanny i know uncanny
god is she good i know and emily ashford
sounds so much like paula jones it's
really crazy she's so good in the show
yeah i mean they're all good taryn's
great beanie's great but
oh my god emily ashford as like
playing these levels of paula jones she
talked about it a little bit about how
that's interesting how they kind of made
her a little bit but you see you see it
performing because paula jones i like
that idea she's being manipulated and
she's having to perform a certain way oh
my god she's excellent so what on that
what a feat like to perform as a as a
person as a real person but then to
perform as a person performing yeah is
like the double it's
really impressive that show and that
show is like you got to see how to watch
it's like
juicy oh yo you know i like juicy yeah
and it reminded shows and it like brings
me back i remember that time so well
but like seeing the you know what's
funny about that the inner workings of
it is fascinating i remember being
really like um split i remember being
really confused by
that scandal at the time because i was
in my early 20s i think or like maybe
like late teens but anyway i was it was
while i was having like my own like
sexual awakening i was like becoming
sexual and like and um and so that to me
was being
demystified and like destigmatized uh in
my own life and so i remember thinking
like well i don't what's the big it's
like
why is that such a big deal what what
you know it's shitty that he did that to
his wife and all that and like but then
there was a part of me too that was
still
you know i grew up a certain way and
like i remember thinking like oh my god
i can't believe he did that so i was
like yeah really that was i remember
thinking more that the second part where
it's like yeah it's so wrong not only to
cheat on your spouse which i still think
it's wrong to do that but also um to do
something
like
dirty i know in the oval office you know
because that was sacred oh yeah exactly
yes and now i don't consider the oval
office why as sacred as i once did why
not um you know things have transpired
over the years in that office
don't stop listening to our show because
of our political beliefs please
uh yeah i know it's pretty wild how
differently i see the hill you know both
have to see the oval office differently
now and less sacred because like god
knows what went down oh my
but not even just in the last 20 years
before that i know things with kennedy i
mean please i remember um
you know in fact i remember going on a
tour uh when obama was in office uh his
guy his right-hand man a reggie he took
me on this amazing tour like so we got
to go into the office and there was a
room off to the side that was like his
like actual office it's like the oval
office is like a little bit more
to my understanding like
when he told us about it was like more
for show kind of it was like that's
where like all the photo ops are taken
and like that's where you see the
president but but there is actually like
a really like nondescript um little
smaller obviously uh kind of hole in the
wall office off to the side of
like a real office a real office and
that's where he does a lot of that and i
remember saying to um the guy that was
showing us really cool guy he uh i said
oh so this is that
that's like during the clinton stuff
that's right he's like yeah that's
that's probably the office where it
mostly happened because the the oval
office that anyone could walk in really
and like there was like he wouldn't do
that there i don't but unless that was
part of the thrill for him i'm saying
part of the power trip part of the like
whatever kink yeah i've never been i've
never been a president i don't know
speaking of kink kinky boots
very good yeah i like that yeah but what
do you have to say now oh great show
great show you're fabulous no i didn't
uh let's read a letter okay
okay from alejandro lopez it's a cool
sounding name alejandro alejandro
alejandro is that what i'm thinking no
you sound just like lady gaga that's
crazy i sound like a gentleman guys
alejandro
alejandro
what would a male um
uh singer like lady gaga lord gaga oh
lord i guess yeah lord gaga better
lord gaga
alejandro alejandro
lord gaga is going to go away right now
i've had too much coffee and my and i
might be uh you might be concussed
this is probably the first show um
i've ever done concussed
subject death faith and family dear
christian and justin thank you for
making my favorite podcast
thank you alejandro i'm wow what i'm a
franciscan priest
assigned his pastor to a parish just one
hour from downtown sydney australia
okay justin do an aussie accent oh no he
told me to alejandro i've been there
i've been here for about six years
for the past two two two i'll be being i
can't oh no i won't do it this is crazy
for the past two i haven't been able to
go home to see my family in the us
because of covet wow i've been a fan of
justin since cheap as creepers it's one
of the scariest movies ever made because
the plot is so crazy and you don't know
what's gonna happen next i especially
love the opening scene the car ride home
very hitchcockian
your podcast has helped me feel con
that's thank you alejandra yeah the
beginning is great because you're so
concerned with getting the accent right
that you were like absorbing
it
well it's also not a compliment to me
really it is yeah i guess a little bit
you're a big part of that movie yeah at
the beginning i i agree with alejandro
it's a lot scarier to me because it's
like you don't see it's before you see
the creator once you see the thing it's
like oh it's like a monster whatever
okay uh
your podcast has helped me feel
connected with friends and family back
home i often listen to it on my runs i
appreciate being able to eavesdrop on
your conversations with famous friends
yet the best part of all is the warmth
respect and joy between you two ah
that's so nice alejandra thank you my
favorite part of the show is the end
when you chat about what just happened
you remind me of my love for my siblings
i have two brothers and a sister we are
all very close like you that's really
nice um
how cool it's very cool very meta that
we're
talking about
this right now when he's saying that he
likes that we talk about this how nice
it is yeah i know it's just a big circle
of nice a couple questions one where did
the
where did the quote we don't both have
to love x or hate y come from
i listen for it in every episode always
funny okay um i don't know that we
can say we know someone okay yeah we
have an exercise okay we have a friend
who
gets historically has gotten
irritated
when justin and i agree
about something
often very mundane like usually mundane
usually mundane like i'd say oh let's
stop and get ice cream for example
and then you'd say oh ice
yeah yeah that sounds great yeah and
it's good cream
this is even like more specific you'd be
like i could go for a mint chocolate
chip ice cream and be like oh yeah i
mean chug the chips this friend would
say oh you don't both have to like
mincha and chocolate chip ice cream but
it got to the point where it was it was
about things making her so
irked and um and like christian said
often about like the most innocuous
things that um
we just found it really funny uh and we
started
recognizing the potential for that every
time we would agree on something and
it's just fun to say yeah it's fun to
say especially when it's about something
very specific and weird obviously like
we do on the show so
thank you for asking and you know it's
funny last night when we saw we were
mentioning sarah
one of the shorties who came to the
screening uh as she like right away said
it really funny you both have to yeah it
was funny yeah that was nice um okay
number two have you ever thought about
having the eldest long brother on the
show these are really good questions it
would be interesting to hear you three
together in one episode yes also very
uh something we've talked about about
and
our older brother uh damian he is
hilarious and we're very close with him
learned so much from him um but he is a
teacher
uh and and the reason i'm like
hesitating in the way i'm speaking is
because
he likes to protect his
anonymity he's very private even though
you just said his name
oh that's okay i mean people can look
people like that he's very private um
and
as much as we'd like him to be on the
show and i think as much as he might
want to be on the show
he is very busy he'd be very funny he's
very busy with his job and raising two
adorable children yes and his name's we
won't mention right uh so he's very busy
and very private so that combination
makes it tricky but hopefully one day
he can come on also he is smarter and
funnier than us so um
maybe there's a little part of us that
thinks he'll we'll be like overshadowed
by him exactly yeah it would be really
nice to have him i would be funny i like
i sort of fantasized about like having
him do like a segment or like he'd call
in every once in a while also um
fans of the show will remember dr dave
from oh that's quarantine episodes and
our brother and dr dave are very close
friends they went to princeton together
and that's how we know dr dave yeah uh
so thanks for asking that alejandro uh
and back to alejandro
finally i noticed that there is a
running theme in your podcast episodes a
fear of death it's very common and even
priests have it god you know i'd love to
talk to him on the show i'd love to talk
to a priest a religious person of any
denomination whenever we're faced with
the great unknown the man of the cloth
yes
or a woman of the cloth or a person of
the class
god whenever we're faced with the great
unknown of any kind human beings don't
handle it very well we either try to
fight it kill it and dissect it or just
avoid it completely pretending it's not
there yeah i can relate to all of that
back to alejandra ultimately i think
what brings me peace is trusting that
god loves me and would never hurt me now
i realize that a lot of people have
trouble trusting in that because of the
hurts of life
my advice to anyone who has trouble
trusting in god's goodness is to trust
in someone who trusts in god's goodness
i found that to be helpful in my own
life while navigating this world that
doesn't always make sense and journeying
towards death and whatever lies beyond
that is that's really nice i feel like i
can trust an alejandro for sure
both of you seem like nice grateful
respectful individuals and i hope you
don't worry unnecessarily
and it's really
kind of i would like to worry less me
too
um you know that's why any i think
that's why my fascination in the
afterlife in any form like
uh ghosts or whatever or having seen
you know having seen signs from
my our recently departed grandmother i
mean so comforting yeah i remember when
she was
you know into her hundreds i was she
would always say you know i don't she
was so funny she'd be like i'd always
ask people before they die like friends
of mine because obviously when you live
to be 104
all your friends end up dying at some
point she'd be like i'd always ask them
to send me a sign from the afterlife
yeah just so i know that yes and she's
like and they never did i always wanted
them to so i was i remember saying to
her
i was like well now's your chance to do
that with us so like that's what you you
know both of us were on the signs from
your departed grandmother
no but while she was alive i really i
know i was like well send me one
and um
she did i mean i got one from i i think
she did too yeah yeah for sure it made
me feel really good um uh back to
alejandra peace and all good father
alejandro lopez ofm conventual
what a great letter oh oh and he gives
some what you rather's
nice would you rather be an or i can't
wait aren't you excited for his would
you rather you're gonna be like fun and
challenging would you rather be an
ordinary person in the mcu or in the
star wars universe
oh that is an ordinary person yeah i
know what he's saying like a um oh i see
yeah um oh i i would pick i would pick
star wars me too
yeah because i'd go to hoth or something
and just lay low you go to hoth yeah
what about
because no one would bother me there oh
i'd go to endor
and play with by far the nerdiest
conversation i've had in like six months
oh yeah i go to endor and like chill
with the ewoks i i get in with the ewoks
but uh but the ewoks are
a little yeah i know they're they're
tribal they're in trouble
they're trouble because they and they
bring trouble on
but hoth you'd have the whole place to
yourself no just because they don't know
they did they they were scared of like
han and leah because they didn't like
they weren't used to seeing humans i
don't think but now they are i would go
to like the post return of the jedi
endor where like they're if you have
that option
you can't pick the time period
or tatooine and just like if you want to
chill
and like be
pointed the point is it's easier to
uh blend in i would say and there's less
danger some people are [ __ ] scared
yes
they're like [ __ ] there's less danger in
the star wars world because you can kind
of do your own thing a little bit easier
whereas the mcu there's always some
battle one of those big cgi bad guys
like just like
vaporizing half the population yeah
yeah it's just too much and thor and
they're like gods flying around like
doing crazy [ __ ] to humanity i would
i would be more comfortable in star wars
speaking of thor justin and i just did
this interview on this australian
morning show yesterday yeah yeah and
they casually
made fun of us by saying that we're like
the hemsworth brothers yeah because
we're nothing like that with brothers
yeah it was like a reverse it was like a
uh comparing us to them only in so as
much as they said sarcastically they're
like they're like you guys are like the
hemsworth brothers
yeah the games with teams with um
okay number oh he's got another would
you rather great would you rather have
three legs which would allow you to move
faster than others with two legs or
three arms which would allow you to
carry more dinner plates the table wow
man where would the extra leg and where
the extra arm would be like it concerns
me i would have your butt area or your
crotch right where your yeah other stuff
is um or just out of your hip
just like next i'd rather have another
arm me too um it would be more practical
i think me too because i don't care
about moving from first yeah it would be
cool to be able to carry more things
also um how many times have you wished
you had another arm also it's and for
certain you know doing things like what
just anytime you're
you know like
coming into contact with people
yeah you could have another amazing for
orgies
also it would be my handshaking arm
because i would keep it just for like
dirty stuff you know how like uh
i think that's where um you know there
was in certain cultures they used to
they wipe their butts with their i think
left hand and so it's very which is why
they only shake with the right feels
like fake news oh i think it's true
maybe something palm made up yeah you
think i remember him saying that yeah
maybe he made it up i think he did uh
maybe not maybe
well fact check on that in either case i
would rather i think there's something
also less um
frightening about having an extra arm
it's kind of hide it easier it's like
having an extra nipple or something it's
like more of a party trick whereas
having an extra leg you look like an
entirely different
species i think you're underestimating
like how different you'd look with an
extra arm
i guess it'd be like pretty charring if
their my extra arm came out of my
sternum uh-huh and you can just keep it
in here uh and i just
picture that i am it's really funny it's
funny you can hide it easier i think
okay how about you just tuck it into
your sweatshirt whereas an extra leg
how do you hide an extra leg
what about this what if it's a limb that
you have no control over we've talked
about this before an uncontrollable limb
and then i would rather have the extra
leg because the extra hand can get you
in trouble
yeah i mean i guess both keep gaining
trouble yeah but easier with an arm
because like you can't you don't grub
someone with your foot unless you're
daniel day-lewis and in that
well or or rex ryan
rex ryan he's a foot fetish doesn't it
he does yo you didn't know that no oh
yeah oh i think maybe i did rex ryan
whatever i don't need to shame him like
no there's nothing wrong with fetishes
anyway uh thank you so much alejandro
father lopez um what a great letter and
you know i i like hearing from uh men
and women and people of the cloth and
from different religions because
oftentimes
religion and religious people get
stigmatized and
i'm guilty of doing that and i'm sure we
do it on this show so it's nice to hear
from christian i grew up with a really
wonderful
catholic priest inspiration in our lives
um father joe he was my godfather and
and he lived a very noble
life like a really beautiful man so i i
like being reminded of the goodness in
in that world too
thank you father lopez and thank you
annalee ashford yes if you guys would
like to write into the show
our email address is life is short at
wondery.com
and we will
talk to you hopefully we'll talk to you
next week okay suffice to say uh it's
been really fun
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life short is hosted by me justin long
it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian and it's also produced by
megan v monaco and katie the allen i
know you're going to do it senior
producer is michelle mead
audio engineer there is sergio enriquez
executive producer is marshall louis for
hungary wondering well that's my
impression of a guy who can't say w's
[Music]
[Applause]
he's comparing her to a dolphin swimming
the ocean that's what it's supposed to
do
her standing up giving a road they're
just getting up there
natural habitat
you know you see dolphins swimming in
the ocean it's like something so
beautiful about seeing something doing
what it's supposed to do you know it was
built to do
he's so aware of it being a show yeah
to the point where he's comparing a
shameless dolphin in the ocean
which is
where a dolphin needs to be to survive
as a creature
where it belongs she needs it's like
he's saying that she needs to do that to
survive as a creature that's the analogy
so what is he going to do with her if
they get together off the ship why would
he ever want to be with her not on the
show
she thinks he would he'd be cruel to do
that because this is where she thrives i
hope she picks him yeah i'm so funny to
see that evolution
oh my god
you